my best friend i grew up with his dad
was in a hospital bed
and uh he
you know he'd be laying down right there
so when he'd come out of his room he had
to talk over the bed
and now i would say hey man you know
oscar devon is fighting over the staples
center man
and uh you know i want to see if you
want to go and i was heard here
and he would go and he would go i want
to go he's like hey putto you haven't
been out of bed in 12 years
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
let's do the show
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my
all right so this guy
gail with that note to me i don't know
who that note's from but i think i know
it's from oh george thank you no no i
said you read it to me come on read it
to you
all right so are we are we going we are
moving sorry we've been
oh my god dude um yo you want to
apologize
first of all i never asked how how is
the podcast doing
uh it's doing well it's started and it's
growing very fast uh the oscar de la
hoya episode
and that depends on the day i guess
oscar de la hoya episode did it amazing
as did the bobby lee episode um
40. all right good oh well no those are
we're on our weight gail
like outlier good by the time we get to
ten
we'll be our in our [ __ ] octagenerian
years which i think you're already there
note here says george thank you for not
killing us when we stole your chingon
beer hey felipe in the what's up full
podcast
so there you go
i think it's time i think we [ __ ]
kill one and send a message eh
did they like it didn't say anything
like that no i i think they drank all
four so i would imagine they did
they i bet they don't know that the cap
is used for uh
to save the beer
all right who in here aaron
do you partake in the marijuana
facilities
i want to read that you have a young
girl
i don't
we got uh oh goodness okay so this is
super chill that's a good one super
chill blue raspberry it's 200 milligrams
of thc and five servings wait a minute
that's a [ __ ] lot so that's a lot so
there's 40 milligrams
you only need two only one one piece of
these
and it's the sort of thing where what is
it so your standard gummy these days i
feel like is
five milligrams that's that's pretty
common so this is the equivalent of
eight
of those guys i am all at once i can't
eat all that no that's that you'd go on
a trip with this stuff
well we're supposed to do it here give
me something welcome back girl i missed
you man welcome back i missed you
wanna tear me a little piece off you got
it how how big do you want to do some
too
yes are you going to do something
i got a dog
i got a doctor
i got four of them he's a new father and
he's trying to okay
so
because
because you you ejaculate you can't have
you can't eat weed
how's that one if i wasn't
what if i was you think i'd be a good
lawyer
i think he'd be an excellent lawyer all
right
let's create a case
let's create a let's create a case and
let me uh argue for what kind of lawyer
would i be for
defense or or or prosecution no you'd be
a defense attorney okay let me get
something to cut this once we do it
right and then we'll
we'll create a scenario for uh
hey grant who [ __ ] your hair up but
you joined the military or this [ __ ]
era
all right so so gil uh can we talk about
your little procedure
yeah
not a little procedure but that that was
that was no it was just disappointing to
me after they did everything they went
in i have no way wait wait now you're
getting ahead all right all right now
you're getting ahead okay
now forget it you're dealing with a
[ __ ] attorney okay all right yes
council and the name of my attorney is
attorneys
[Laughter]
hey how much more you think if if
if that was my
my attorney name vergas panochazymas i
think you'd get a lot of business and
then i'll be like this every debbie
button let me burn that thing you'd have
every choice in l.a
no you could wear whatever you want with
a name like that
where's the thing
is it right there yeah
uh
how do they start
hi i'm george lopez and i'm the lead
attorney of veris verism
do you have a complaint with a neighbor
does your dog bark a lot have you
thought about poisoning them don't do
that just give us a call over here at
bergaspanocha
somebody's going into a divorce or a
conflict
with a loved one and the number is
p a l o
b i g
eight one two
and the actual numbers eight one eight
five three three eighteen four eight one
two that that i don't know i didn't know
the numbers but
there you go these we can cut that out i
think i'd have to do another comment i
don't like that one
and espanol
see tutin
is that the right spell in there is this
on the monitor whatever it is check it
out on the monitor up there what is is
that the right spelling did our number
put up
that's almost like a native american
girl yeah that's good pocahontas
would you want me to cut that thing yeah
cut it half half is 20.
[ __ ] you eight less than half less than
half i mean i know
so um there's a few things i'm going to
talk to you about here so so
uh um you don't need to go into the
procedure thing though but but
because i was ill with my with my kidney
transplant so when it whenever
what's this about 10.
so it's equivalent like two sort of
standard dummies how much are you doing
i'll go one for one i'm not going to
work i'm not going 10 by myself
because you know what
if i get too much marijuana and i start
to ejaculate i don't think that happens
not here please
i'm on the other side is that your
father you can't he's already died i'm
look look all the mess that costs me
i don't know what i don't know what i'm
trying to do with this
okay here we go
i thought i was going to golf later on
but it doesn't appear like i am
just by this
man
okay oh that tastes good
okay
you're having a procedure done
and your heart was set on one day right
and then they changed the date on you
yes
yes because there was other emergencies
emergencies came in
and then they sent it to another day yes
and then um
it happened then
yes they did the procedure the second
time around same doctor
same doctor okay
as far as i know i was out by the time
he
he gave me that stuff
yeah give me the good stuff
put me out
with a purple phone yes
what's up they gave michael jackson yeah
i came out dancing like michael jackson
but
when you left the hospital did you have
a little seven-year-old dressed in the
same clothes that you were wearing
[Laughter]
fortunately i had my wife there driving
alleged that's all alleged by the way
yeah of course
um
and uh
do you feel good immediately after that
or or was it uh i didn't there was a
little bit of discomfort so you had a
little heart thing there's a little bit
of but i think overall over time it's
been the reason why you had a little
lightheadedness right yeah but they
didn't answer my questions
now what was the question guys well the
question the procedure was to find out
how much my valve was actually leaking i
have a leaking valve on the ventricle
side of my heart
and they went in they've done they've
done this thing once before and when
they did it the first time they said it
was leaking
slight to moderate
so you know what that's [ __ ] man i
mean uh slight to moderators i need
numbers
i think you need numbers right well
why would a doctor say slight to
moderate i i i don't know how they how
they categorize it and
they're calling this and they go to
medical school i don't so you know you
got to accept it if all the doctors are
going to say the same thing
okay that's a good question now
erin you too do do you think that
it's proper for a doctor to dumb down
his diagnosis to a person
because
if he
because he has to make it so that you
understand it instead of giving you the
actual percentage and the actual number
and the actual saying that this is what
we want
to optimize the optimum way is this and
then there's a 9 leakage here and then
potentially we're going to get it down
to that instead of saying
slight to moderate i want i want more
information than just a doctor saying to
me you know it's slight to moderate
wouldn't you well i i'd like that but
only
i'm i'm a realist in realizing that i've
never been to medical school and now i
have two doctors saying the same thing
you know calling the two different
doctors from the from a very reputable
hospital and the last doctor that called
it was supposed to be a world renowned
uh doctor so i accept what he says and
he said select a monitor too yes and i
don't i don't agree with that they what
what they did was
the first time they did it when they put
the camera they take camera and stick it
all the way into my heart and they look
and they come out and they say slight to
moderate the explanation given to me if
it's slight we're not gonna do anything
with it if it's moderate we'll leave it
up to your cardiologist to decide if he
wants to go in and mess with it
came out my cardiologist said no
so
i've been having fluid build up but wait
a minute okay but your cardio already
just said no but that's a dude that's
your friend right no this is the regular
cardiologist that i go to at the
facility okay he said no you know
we're gonna treat it with medicine
because i keep building fluid up right
and so we're doing that and now i'm
questioning because i'm saying you know
what i can't keep
i'm not a doctor but i've only got one
kidney okay so
my primary care physician says
what you're doing is working right now
but
you can't keep doing that because it's
eating up it'll waste your kidney that's
right so i went back i said no we've
been doing this for a while it's not
working let's get a second opinion
that's when they sent me back that's
when i get the world renowned doctor
okay so the first thing they do is they
put me in the hospital and they give me
a echo cardio stress test so just like
an echocardiogram where they put that
machine and they hear your heartless
yeah okay i'm laying down on the bed
they do that
and then they said now it's time for the
stress test but that's not the doctor
that does it's a nurse right yes that's
not him so then i'm laying down in bed
but they like bicycle pedals at the end
of the bed yup and they get they put
pressure they put stress on those they
make it harder you go faster make it
harder so it's stressing your your heart
is going
he gets the results of those tests
when i went back to see him
he says
okay those results say
that under resting
you're slight to moderate but under
stress
you are now
moderate to severe okay because
what do you make of that i'm gonna tell
you what i make of it uh what the the
difference or just the fact that they're
not using numbers and just talking just
like the moderate i mean that seems so
there's no [ __ ] time that you've been
sitting there have you been [ __ ]
listening to it i'm just listening
although i am already feeling like this
i didn't exactly i did ten and i'm
already feeling like hot
isn't deja vu that strip club around
here
okay no because what i what i see is
and and i didn't go to medical school
but i did
watch julia when i was a kid
remember she was a nurse with a little
black kid that
remember that yeah
remember julia no she was hot i mean she
was a nurse right with a little kid and
you know that little kid works at dodger
stadium is that right yep
his mama looked good although michael j
wagodor that was i think that was his
best friend i don't know what happened
to that
remember his name no michael j wagon let
me see if it's on here what was what was
the uh
julia's son's best friend i'm trying to
talk about a tv history trying to think
of her real name who knows so uh diane
carroll yeah
that was her
and the guy who played her son her son
was let me see
it doesn't say son's best friend so yeah
porky or some [ __ ] like that his friend
was michael j wagador
okay we have
not leonard there's a leonard wagodorn
uh that one there you go that's close
it's close who's the white kid right
hank brandt is who who played aussie
there's not even a picture of him
and the little kid wasn't what was what
was her son's name
corby
she was big cory baker cory baker mark
my
i was my case there you go mark coppage
that's the actor okay so
and i mean
let's i don't want to talk about what
kind of insurance you have i'm sure it's
better than
kaiser or some [ __ ] in the middle of
night no it's going to church you get uh
the dude that
trudeau remember that guy trudeau that
was a big infomercial dude who's still
got like 25 years to do
prison he misled everybody oh no kevin
trudeau i'll let that [ __ ] up too
that's [ __ ] man
you want you know what
here's a good thing you and i have lived
the life we're smart dudes how old are
you
28. anytime you talk about some [ __ ]
that what happened back then these
[ __ ] got to go to the computer
to look up stuff and you and i can just
talk about okay because we live in that
time
in that time and that's that's right uh
kevin kevin mark trudeau the american
author salesman convicted fraudster and
where is he right now he is
still in prison north power sell four
man uh eligible for a lease next year
so is hinckley
then he can get out hinckley's out but
they're thinking about next year uh
releasing them of all supervision and
everything
i don't agree with that
a lot of people don't can you write down
about hinkley because i think i saw a
story last night about him out there
yeah that's just something new they've
announced today let's see
i don't agree that he's out
all right they've agreed that january
first do you think we can find his phone
number and call him he wins
unconditional release hang on but we're
still talking about about about gil how
about girl's heart okay so so here's
what i see
so
and i'm not a doctor yes i understand
that and i never even
you know with a nurse so i'm completely
out of medical field
but when you're laying in bed
and you're not using the pedals it's
moderate
okay it's slight slight yes and then
they bring the pedals in
and then you start to pedal and then
they do the test and what did he say was
moderate to severe okay and why is that
because your blood is moving through
yourself because my heart is working
more
and that that's why so when that
happened
to be honest with you i was happy
i was happy because i was told
that once you're when it's moderate
they leave it up to the doctor to go
ahead and decide your cardiologist when
it's severe
they'll take care of it right away
so he said it was moderate to severe
so now we go to the second doctor i get
the visit with the second doctor
the world renowned doctor you don't want
to say his name
no you don't have decisions yeah good
because i don't remember him
so well you know what thanks for being a
good patient car for your [ __ ] dog
car i'm a car you don't have to say his
name
and and so he's the world renowned guy
he says okay now i've got this from the
echocardiogram
i know what they've looked at the first
time because when they did it the first
time they did a scope so somebody
another physician was looking at my
valve actually and is that the thing
that goes like that no no this is they
stick a camera down and they're actually
watching it leak
they suck a camera down your throat
they sent it through my through my
shoulder back here and it went in there
and did you feel any of that by the way
no i was out okay i was out so
uh
so now he has when they did it the first
time with the camera they said slight to
moderate now he's got a machine telling
them not visualizing it but the echo
saying moderate to severe under stress
and the first one they did was no stress
it was resting heartbeat
so just regular heartbeat i'm laying
down doing nothing so now under stress
they're saying moderate to severe with
the machine
so the specialist the world-renowned guy
comes in he says
i want to put him back under i want to
go through
in his down and in his heart again i
want to see it myself okay and he
explains man when you're under we're
gonna
give you some medicine to stretch your
heart out to make it work
so that way i'll see it under stress and
i'll see it with the naked eye you know
with this camera wow so i said okay and
while we're at it have you ever had an
angiogram i said no
he said okay we're going to give you an
angiogram at the same time to make sure
that nothing is blocked in there anymore
wait a minute you never had antigua
never had an ing crab nobody did but is
that it because you never go to the
doctor or because the doctor never
requested it doctor never requested it
no i've been going to cardiology i've
been seeing doctors and nobody's ever
requested they've all said the same
thing and the cardiologist before you
even say the cardiologist my my regular
one
not the second offense
no no the the one that's my friend is my
is my uh primary care physician that's
the one that tells everybody to get
[ __ ] if you ask me
and so
he
the primary cardiology he told me he's
given me
an echo stress test before
and he says
they're going to give you uh
this angiogram he said they're not going
to find anything he says
they're clean they're clear i know they
are because i've been watching you're
clean they gave me the angiogram
angiogram shows i'm clean all the
arteries and veins are clean wow so now
it's time once the i'm in there for the
angiogram the finishing angiogram and he
says okay
and the nurse is monitoring and she's
are you in any pain yet and when they
did the angiogram
first they started in my wrist
and so they went in through my wrist
they went out my arm they did all this
[ __ ] do they numb it at all no no wow it
was in there and i it wasn't bothering
me i could take it here you had that
done erin
listen man i don't think i could sit
there
and have somebody put something through
that's going to end up going to my heart
with with no
sedatives i you know
it doesn't bother me so they did it and
didn't bother me but then they told me
they started shaving me matter of fact i
even asked them hey are you using uh
uh my escape mansky i said here usually
she's we're gonna have to shave her
groin i said hey wait i thought they
were gonna go through my wrist she says
we do but as a precautionary in case you
have problems with your wrist they'll
end up going through your groin and
that's when when they're doing it i said
hey are you using manscape those are
supposed to shoes i don't know what
we're using these are just cheap ones
from the hospital she says but they
really were good they're plastic energy
so i don't know what it was
okay forget about that let's talk about
did a woman shave it
yeah yeah wow man so tell me how that is
like like you go in there
you take all your clothes off you have a
robe on right
and then she comes in i'm just with some
shaving cream no no shaving cream oh
no she just went in there with the
gloves or anything
she had gloves on that helps the
toughest part was getting
my nut i had to go like this
am i done
you know so i know how you do that
i worked on you in junior high i tried
to do it but after two years i gave up
some of my friends could move their nuts
by moving their chin but i couldn't do
it
so you go have you ever been shaved down
there before uh not by someone else a
medical professional no
so she goes down there
does she turn the lights down and put on
some music
did you know it was going to happen or
were there no they just no
they surprised me with it i didn't care
i've never been shaped so so
she lifts up your gown
yeah she didn't throw away her just a
little bit you know
and then i'm laying down she comes in
she has to grab just to grab your
testicles right yeah well she had to
have some help for that you know coming
out with these things are heavy
so who helped her a male nurse
somebody she went to high school or
she didn't bring a friend or had to be a
nurse yeah so they got in there they
went to a clinic one time that my friend
told me that the nurse brought a girl
that lived next door to her because they
were short staffed
[ __ ]
i think you missed the you had a short
stamp they want her
so she goes in there
they shave it
well don't just say it like that
that they
they put cream on it
no
no did she hold your penis to make sure
that she like was she holding it like
that i don't remember she hold her just
push it out of the side you know got a
rope with a weight on the other end
on that side you didn't you didn't get
that
i left no no i was more concerned i
didn't want her to cut me
you know i wasn't nervous or anything
just hey do it it's just she's a nurse i
didn't care you know you didn't get hard
no no i didn't you think with a guard uh
no i'd be way too like i don't know
nervous or just especially if i didn't
know it was coming i'd be like just just
get over with him
yeah say it he was no biggie you know
so they did it it also just is also just
the one side like it's uneven yeah well
yeah you know i haven't checked but no
they did both sides oh as a matter of
fact because i remember saying just one
side well just in case you have to go to
the other side it's very strange i think
it's strange because they could ask you
to do it at home i could say hey do you
mind would you mind they've done it to
me before
uh not here years ago for surgery and
they they did it back then they don't
ask you
they did it back then they did it with
with uh shaving cream you didn't you
think that
they would ask especially where the
things are that they would say okay
tomorrow you're gonna have a procedure
because you know sometimes you know they
make you clear yourself out yeah those
things but they wouldn't say hey would
you mind shaving this area tomorrow so
that when we go in there it's already
taken care of no matter of fact before i
went in there i was told they were gonna
do it through the wrist you didn't put
cologne or anything down and i always
put coal down there just in cases
because you know
you never know before she grabs it hey
if you if you stay ready you have to you
don't have to get rid of it you have to
get ready see whether you know she's not
going to be like yeah the last thing i
want to do is ever go like this and go
did she did she use a hot towel or
anything she just
no no initially it was like a yeah it's
just a it's a medical procedure it's not
done sexually yeah so there was there
was no problem with it they did it they
wrapped me up like a tamale they took me
down into the
the room they did it and then
they started with the first the
angiogram they're pushing all this [ __ ]
through it and they explained to me and
they said okay they're talking i can
hear them yeah this is a long shot
though this i mean this is a long shot
but you know the world
you know moves in a you know a weird
design right sure weird design
i'm telling you dude
listen this is a long shot but your long
shots win the kentucky derby there you
go it wasn't the girl that was your
girlfriend in third grade
i'm not gonna say that you could have oh
no no no because you know some crazy
[ __ ] happens man when you'd be like oh
my god
no that it wasn't her all right
so so then
like i
you know like i get where if you're calm
then you know if your blood pressure you
know if you're if you're
you're doing stuff and then it goes up
but
i don't think anybody wants
any leakage in their heart at any time
like you know uh if you're watching if
you're somebody sitting around you'd
want to get it repaired the only thing
i'm a realist you know and i understand
i'm not a medical doctor but i
understand i'm not dying from this [ __ ]
yet so it's not like i'm in
no no emergent
but you're starting to feel things yeah
i wanted to feel before where you would
like it like exactly i wanted to get
well but i mean it's not like oh [ __ ]
i'm gonna die next week or i'm gonna
have a heart attack because everybody i
don't think you like when you got up or
you get lightheaded i don't you know you
you're a guy you're a sheriff you're in
vietnam you know you you you know you
chase people down you travel and all
that stuff but it wouldn't want to be
something because i think what happens
is
once you start to kind of say oh i'm
kind of okay like this and then if you
start to
get lightheaded in the morning and you
don't want to say anything and you sit
down that you don't want it to become
part of your life yeah that's what i
don't want and i exp i had a long talk
with my wife and i told her like i said
i told you right away i was disappointed
you know and i am disappointed i i want
a doctor to tell me
okay wake up and smell the coffee that's
the way you're gonna be the rest of your
life we're not gonna be able to fix it
or
let's fix it right you know i don't have
you know that that's all i want right
that just fix it or [ __ ] or get off the
pot because it's fixable yes you want it
yes i want it to be fixed and and i'm
not afraid of doctors i'm not afraid of
surgery right any of that [ __ ]
so
they went in they put the
and then all of a sudden they said now
this thing going to work
and they start pulling the [ __ ] out of
my arm
and so what they did was they said i had
too many arteries that were veins or
whatever they were going all over the
place on the inside
so they didn't have enough
wire or camera [ __ ] to go down yeah so
then they pulled it out and then they
stuck it in my groin they ended up going
through my groin so they could get the
bottom half
and that was a little uncomforting you
know that was that was uncomfortable but
i know i've got a high pain threshold
and they're they didn't put sedative in
that either no i couldn't do it i know
no sorry i couldn't do it they they were
in there
and
and i don't remember maybe they did give
me a shot i don't know but i know they
didn't give me any major
stuff
and the nurse was saying are you okay i
said yeah i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine
finally says you know what you say
you're fine but i saw your eyes and i
saw you make a little grimace they're
hurting a little bit down and i can
remember they were not totally
intolerable but it was a little little
painful they were putting pressure it
just felt like they were putting a lot
of weight pushing that the needle in you
know trying to get it in there and says
i'm gonna give you something for pain he
says you're not asking for it but i
think you need it so they gave me a shot
to ease it up a little bit but then
shortly thereafter the doctor said one
other doctor that was in there came in
he says okay
he says uh i'm gonna give you some stuff
that's gonna put you to sleep he said
don't worry about it we're gonna tape
your eyes so you can't open your eyes
and that's the last thing i remember him
saying anything
it's funny you say that because that's
what mom used to do to me when her
boyfriend came over and take my [ __ ]
eyes
[ __ ] [ __ ] out there and i'm trying
to look around with with tape dice
so they did it next thing i know i woke
up and i'm out i'm in my room i'm in the
i'm in recovery 100 sealed up yeah all
they know not 100 because they made me
lay there you can't move couldn't move
my arm couldn't move my leg
uh for four hours
and they had weight on it a little bit
you know don't move it because made
arteries you know so it wouldn't bleed
out my arm would bleed
and at the end of four hours you know
okay go home
and i and i told the doctor you know the
doctor came in
and it wasn't that the the meadow meadow
guy somebody else that had been in there
with him comes in and tries explaining
everything to me says well under stress
you know it was slight to moderate
and he says so there is no difference i
said wait a minute doc before you guys
we need to talk
you know
you you tell me slight to moderate
nothing's being done you're not going to
change anything they're not going to put
the clip in there yet i still keep
getting fluid build up i said i don't
like that they take me having lasix i
got a triple up for three days in a row
i said i've only got one kidney i've got
one doctor telling me this is going to
kill my kidney i've got another doctor
saying do good you know this is keeping
the fluid out i said and my wife has
documented between may and june nine
times i went down
i said how do we explain that
doc we got to do something about i mean
and he looked and he said
i was totally unaware of the nine times
that you're saying you fell i said we've
got them all documented
i said
both the other doctor the number two guy
and this guy i told both of them now
granted
the first my original cardiologist he
didn't know because i hadn't seen him in
three or four months he didn't know that
i'd been going down that many times
and
when i told him because he said why did
you go through this
why did you seek a second opinion why
did and how did you get into this doctor
right and when i told him and i told him
why i'm not afraid of any doctor you
know you're i'm just a man you're just a
man you're maybe you're more educated in
medicine that doesn't mean you're
any better than anyone so i can tell you
like a man man man doc this is what's
going on
okay you've got all this knowledge i
don't now what are you gonna do about it
how are you gonna and that doctor
to
discredit he put his hand on my shoulder
and he says i'm so sorry my friend i
didn't realize he said we're gonna take
care we're gonna get the bottom of it so
i believe they're sincere and trying to
get to the bottom of it
so now i've got to
get another appointment in with that
doctor because now they're going to
confer
he said we're going to get together he
said they're talking about putting a
heart monitor on me for two months or
some [ __ ]
i don't know i just want him to but you
know i don't i don't like that that guy
thought that you could live like that
yeah and that he wouldn't even did the
other guy know that you went down nine
times
no not until i told him when i went in
to see
him because i i just don't i you know
because you know those things lead to
other things yeah and and my primary
care the doctor that i love
that guy when i told him that's what he
said we need to get a second opinion he
doesn't know why they're not doing that
that's right so he's he's in my and i
see him tomorrow
it'll be a very interesting
visit with him tomorrow i'm kidding will
you tell him everything that's going on
with all this stuff no doubt everything
because you know even if you have a slow
leaking attire eventually that thing is
gonna exactly
all you're doing is prolonging the
problem let's get to the bottom of it
yeah and i don't think you want to live
like that like it like no you're active
guy you're doing stuff you don't you
don't want to live where
um
you know you have something like that i
i find myself you know let's go well i
don't know if i want to go with it right
now you know
we're normally let's go
now i got to think about
rest i taking the pills am i doing this
and i don't want it has it affected the
bottles at the bfw no well only because
they they miss me
you know and when i don't go why don't
you bring those guys in here and have
them be gas sometimes
they but they got some stories
yeah they're yummy
these guys are uh
so so
are are you on lasiks do they make you
urinate more or are you on
you're not in any pain no i'm not in any
pain but
if you they expect for you to urinate
every day right yes i take
uh
on a regular basis i take two pills of
lasix a day okay which just gets me
going but
it doesn't work strong enough because i
can feel fluid building up in there man
and i don't like it it feels like i'm
getting like like a beer belly you know
i can feel it
and so it's not you could feel where the
fluid is i can feel i don't feel exactly
where the fluid i feel my stomach
getting distended
and let me tell you so they say okay for
three days double up on your medication
now that means i'm taking four lasiks a
day
and i can tell you the last time i did
it was about three weeks two weeks ago
now
and in two days 13 pounds nothing but
fluid
yeah that's how much excess fluid i
carry
what do you think
that's a lot of fluids
are you happy with these doctors yes yes
i i'm satisfied
because
when you get so many doctors you know
you don't know which one we don't know
which one's the best one which one's
this we're not doctors okay so those
guys went in there and they did the
procedure on you right you went into the
procedure yes and now what's the
prognosis so they went in there they
didn't do it 100 right they they did
what they're supposed to do the testing
was 100
it was the results that i was not happy
with
the results because i wanted him to say
yes let's go in and clip it let's stop
the fluid
let's stop the leakage that way we can
stop the fluid build up yeah but they
had they they can't they won't and the
bottom line they say right now
the risk
outweighs the benefits
they're saying wow it's a little risky
going in there putting that clip on your
heart
and so it's better to keep it leaking a
while before we decide to make that move
that's a risky move
and i sit there and say i mean puerto
madre just
so they say it's it's it's easier to
just leave it
right now that's what they're saying
because it's too delicate to go back in
there and try to
well it's too deli the the risk of
putting what they have to put in my
valve
i ideally the easy fix would be replace
the valve
and but they can't do that because i've
only got one kidney because there's
other stuff that goes along you have to
contrast you have to do a lot of [ __ ] to
get it prepared
and the one kidney can't take it the
contrast that they put in there is too
much for my kidney
all the doctors say the same thing about
that so then
the other way to do it
and if they put a new valve in then that
would stop leakage 100
the valve would just work normal
what they have is they have something
it's it's a little thing they call it i
think they call it a clip
they put it in there and that takes care
of the leakage problem
not a hundred percent
because
but not as drastic it's not having the
class yes yes
at some point
and since this is the podcast and stuff
like you know some older people or
people who have like relatives that
you know they're afraid to go to the
doctor right were you ever afraid to go
to the doctor never
but but there's a lot in our culture
there's a lot of people that sure that
don't go to the doctor sure my
generation too and and their generation
so they're afraid
but if you're afraid
um you're gonna end i mean well
it's only gonna get worse
like you you know we know
you know if you get up and if you have a
pain here or sometimes even somebody
will say you know i was shaving and i
had this thing here and it turns into
like it's throat cancer or a cancer in
your neck and they just ignore it
because they're afraid
so what we want to say to people that if
if they heard any of this
like you didn't have that at all and
then it started a little gradually right
then it got a little bit worse and then
you started to get lightheaded and then
you thought when you first started to
get lightheaded what did you think that
it was it reminded me of something it's
called vasovagal syncope
and that's what i i had before they
diagnosed it they did tests on it they
said that's what it is
they gave me medication for it that
medication
made me extremely lethargic
at that time you know that's what it
does man you know people just say like
[ __ ] that i don't want to live like that
because all of a sudden they're slow and
it's lethargic and they can't do stuff
but what is it what does that medicine
do it makes them lethargic it slows
their whole system slows it all down and
i mean at the time that this was coming
on i'm glad i was in the peak of
physical i was running five miles a day
yeah and
then i took this and all of a sudden i
stopped running
weights started coming on i couldn't do
[ __ ] and i told the dock right this is
killing me doc
and
so that doctor died
and the other doctor took over his
practice said how did that talk what did
he die of heart attack
yeah he said let's start weaning you off
he told me at that time sherman block
was the sheriff of los angeles county he
says sherm's a friend of mine i golf
with him he says but i got to tell him
that homicide is killing his men
he says the stress over there homicide
is just it's it's way too much it's
killing those guys
um let's talk about stress so str stress
shows up as
in in your system
um
what is it like let's say if if if i
walked outside right now and there was a
fight and people were shooting at each
other my stress level go up but it would
go up because of what i saw right
exactly yeah and and um but if i'm
sitting around the house and if i'm
worried about something does that make
my stress level is it mental yes
it's mental that becomes stress on your
heart and on your
on your nervous system what happens
when i was can you define stress yeah
i'm pretty sure i have a good idea which
is like your body stress your action is
your body releasing cortisol right it's
a stress hormone and kind of like nos
for a vehicle right like you can go
really fast for a while but it'll
probably do some damage to the car and
it's that sort of thing where like this
the cortisol will hit other stuff maybe
shoot out adrenaline and it'll get you
going so like you see a fight you're
just here you just
adrenaline
okay
i learned in vietnam you know what i'm
gonna tell you something right now
i met this girl thomas
and you know i had bad kidneys so i told
her that you know i was starting to work
out and training
and i went to bed and she thought it was
pissed and i convinced her it was
adrenaline
right
go ahead
sorry interrupt i learned when i was in
vietnam that if you panic you died on my
body
so when i learn in vietnam you panic you
die people die when you panic so you
can't panic you got to remain calm okay
so that's true too so so forget about
vietnam like like like
any situations where
um
road rage
yeah so somebody gets out of the car
like hey [ __ ] your adrenaline
starts pumping you're going
i don't mind i just i control everything
yeah i keep everything inside i
internalize everything
and i don't let a bunch of stuff but
you're also a trained professional
that's right well i'm trained that's why
i got started my training you know over
overseas come back i learned that's the
way it is did you have that temperament
to some degree to even before or was
that something you really feel like you
learned i don't remember about it any
anything before it was something i i
learned just remain calm don't panic
okay so do this well all the people that
watch this and there's a lot of all
people are all crazy now because they're
trying to go to work and there's no mess
and stuff like that so if somebody's
going to work or they're on the streets
and somebody is following them and they
go around they flip them off they throw
something at them and then the guy had
that guy has road rage that person
should the other person should never get
out of the car right no let it go yeah
there you go
and and that's that's what i've done all
my life and it doesn't mean it doesn't
mean somebody pointing a gun at you or
somebody road rage or anything like that
something as simple as family stress
yeah
that you don't want to you you know i
don't feel like finding so you just hold
everything in
but you'll talk about it you don't want
to create problems you got this you got
that so i just internalize
everything so what happens with that
vasovagal syncope
the layman's version is
i internalize everything my body starts
building up adrenaline
so that i can maintain my calmness
my body produces an overabundance of
adrenaline that has an effect with my
nervous system that tells it the whole
body shut down right now okay
and i go down and once you fall down on
the ground once i'm down on the ground
and prone out
it's like plugging me right back in
then i'm fine again
no problem
so that's what was going on back then
they put me on this pill
that made me lethargic kept me calm
didn't let me get out of control so
everything's fine but yeah i didn't like
it so we weaned myself off and i haven't
been on that pill
at least 15 20. what did that make you
what did that pill take away from you
did it take away
um
did you go to the bhw with those dudes
well i didn't go to the vhw or the bfw i
didn't go to either one of them at that
time
i didn't at that time i wasn't going to
the bfw at that time
i was i was working okay well let's talk
about something important yeah did you
go to stephen's state council when you
were like oh most assuredly i used to
live at stevens state house
adrenaline when you were like third year
you were you still went to stephenstown
yeah
what did steven say about us so what
you're talking about yeah stephen's
takeout's the greatest has steven heard
the chatter
no i haven't talked to him lately i've
been meaning to call him he's had a lot
of the boys
italian sicilian of course going in the
gym you know they uh
he just sent his daughter off to college
up and i want to say in new york
someplace i'm sure
columbia university why everybody sounds
like a space uh nice nice everybody in
that area is dying his daughter's gonna
go over there
you know start her own business
about those diana i just saw where he
put on a concert
uh you've pro have you performed there
before you been there stevens
yeah yes no
maybe are you serious
yeah
listen i've never i've never been there
when you're not this dude oh okay i'm
george lopez oh [ __ ] i saw frank
sinatra's perform there
you know so it's been there for
years and years and years what what year
franklin i wasn't performing there oh
[ __ ] it had to be back in the
60s early 60s lately
yeah you got it down there i don't know
let me check the archives let's see if
it shows up
wow that's pretty incredible how much
did you pay him i have no idea probably
got produce for a year
that was a grandfather drug that was a
grandfather that had him back then yeah
i mean a lot of people have been there
he just had in front of stevens
he had uh there's a small street between
eastern and atlantic right there he
closed off the street i just saw it on
facebook that's awesome
closed off the street and had a concert
right in front of us right in front of
you this weekend a couple weeks ago who
who performed there i don't know momo no
no
it wasn't a comedian you know i'm almost
thinking about buying the company from
the butler from trump my pillow
hey
so um one would just send me something a
year or moments in it yeah
probably somebody
they're doing their paranormal stuff on
yeah
and momo said that they were just back
in el paso at some cemetery
and they were at the
cemetery that richard ramirez yeah sleep
in yes and so they went by there and
they're looking at the headstone
and that they saw a shadow across the
headstone and i don't know where doneti
started crying
yeah just started crying
yeah and why i didn't want to say
anything because he was serious about
his crime but that's what have been my
first statement you know but and uh you
think that's true do you think that
there's no
i don't believe in that [ __ ]
so so so let's say in our in our
families like that in our family you see
somebody that's older that i mean
respectfully man like you you've taken
pretty good care great not pretty good
care you're taking great care of
yourself
but i'm sure that you have to have
either friends or relatives that don't
sure so when you see them and they're
walking up and they get to your house
they're tired
that's the result of something blockage
in their heart or something going on
with themselves right
yeah is it necessary that they do that
or is it if they don't go to the doctor
then those things happen right without
me being rude to them or anybody or
let's just say anybody yeah without
being rude to them or anybody they're
penn decos you know if they don't want
to take care of themselves i'm not here
to take care of themselves and people
are struggling every day every day you
know
and well-meaning friends you know tell
your [ __ ] you know well you ought to go
see this hey i know a kurandera that'll
take care of you over here they won't go
and and so i i don't
uh
i have some very good friends that are
very sick
that still you know i don't believe in
that i'm not gonna do that i don't give
a [ __ ] what the doctor
don't i have a family member said that i
don't give a [ __ ] with a dog okay well
then don't don't complain to me about it
do what you got to do you know best
don't spend your money on doctors do
what you got to do and then also there's
some people like you know maybe they're
big dodger fans and maybe they would go
to the games and even maybe my
grandparents go to the game and struggle
to walk to the
back to the car
and you know we we finally got a little
good angioplasty and what what does the
doctor say to him you know we you just
had this done
you know don't walk for a week and he
walked and got a blood clot and he
[ __ ] died the doctor told him don't
walk
but but if people they don't go
and then all of a sudden they can't go
to dodger games so they can't go to the
market anymore because they can't walk
through the market without having
shortness of breath but that's that all
that stuff can be taken away right sure
like it could be it could be
you know and and all these
and and i don't understand and somebody
said it
uh
i either read it on you on the internet
or sought on the news uh and i'm not not
taking a stand pro or anti-vaccine
because
i know i'm vaccinated matter of fact i
go get my booster tomorrow morning
but
people that don't want to go get it
i'm vaccinated so i'm sure you know
through some of the fluid out there end
up on you
it's an x-ray so it's clean
they won't go they won't go get the the
vaccine and people won't go to the
doctor
because they're afraid but yet when
they're really sick
man they go to them same doctors that
tell them you should have taken the
vaccine yeah you know how do you listen
so i i just worry about myself all right
so let's talk a little bit about that
okay because because yesterday
is being vaccinated a government issue
is i mean is the government trying to
put something in your blood i don't
think that doesn't you know but these
things happen though man
yeah you read about this [ __ ] fictional
[ __ ]
there's in movies you know they're going
to follow you they're going to die you
know now they'll know where every you're
i don't care i have to write down what
are the pros and the cons the pros are
be careful it may save my life
is that good sure
it may save my life that's the pro the
con is maybe the government will find
out what i'm doing they're spying on me
i don't give a [ __ ] let them follow them
let them follow me to take a [ __ ] if
they want to i don't care
you have to wait in your own life the
good and the bad to make your own
decisions i personally don't well listen
you know i'm not going to tell anybody
what they should do but
the majority of a lot of the people that
are unvaccinated or even some that are
vaccinated
are
are passing away man sure eight new york
city police officers one's 23 and
they're all on ventilators and um
incubators or whatever they call things
like that yeah those guys are down man
sure
and that's from being unvaccinated i
don't you know i don't want to be
[ __ ] 60 years old and think that
there's two or three [ __ ] americas
when i was growing up there was only one
and watching golf a little bit this
this weekend
and the united states one it when
they're yelling usa to me
it
i'll tell you man it doesn't mean what
it used to mean to me when somebody else
usa usa usa
it doesn't have this
i just don't think i don't feel the same
on that i don't i don't feel like i
belong in the that america that those
guys are are yelling at especially when
you have people tell you go back where
the [ __ ] you came from i i was born in a
general hospital
yeah so
it's my united hospital today yeah
yeah so so so the usa usa usa
and the whole immigration thing like
they turned it into almost like a
political football
it's all it is the same
if you look at old
quotes and statements
viewing what they said
you know on immigration yeah you know
those cages that trump were putting
people in those animal cages those are
built by obama
and they were usually they were used for
the same thing but you never heard
any negative about it then
you just but that doesn't mean like you
know i i i you know campaigned for obama
and eight a little bit in 12 but very
disappointed by him over the eight years
[ __ ] taxes went to like 50 it's like
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
so so when people think that i'm like an
obama guy like
you know live and die with them i don't
i don't live in that with obama i'm a
united states citizen i go i i usually
support the president when i believe
that the president
knows something political not when some
[ __ ] bullfall that [ __ ] golfs and
could give a [ __ ] about anybody but
himself
who really only wanted kuliata's
daughter alleged and he would be happy
he would have ran
that
wrong
i don't care who the president is i i
really don't and i would be just as
proud
to shake
joe biden's hand as i would obama's hand
as i would bill clinton as i would trump
george bush they're the president of the
united states i don't give a [ __ ] and
i'm not one that's going to sit there
and say that's not my president no he's
the president united states as long as
i'm here
a resident citizen in the united states
of america that's my president do i
agree with him
no maybe i don't agree with him but he's
still the president and all these things
that are created that have created this
division
between us i i don't know what is ever
going to get us back
uh to the point where when somebody
starts chanting
usa
that we're all back on the same page
i don't
i don't feel
uh
the same
i feel the same as you but i don't think
but also let's say if you look at um
you know i'm friends with the kennedys
and
i thought
yeah okay
so
one of the
one of the kennedy children
i think is bobby jr
is in favor of sir hans her hand being
released from prison
and um
kerry kennedy who i know i know both of
them but she's not
and i find it interesting that i mean i
don't have a father but if my father was
shot by somebody man and i'm not sure i
would ever be cool with
him being free
so so in in between
you know the kennedy family there's
dissention because you know they both
have the same father and
one is not happy that
the the brother is
you know
submitting that he'd be released
you were around that time right
certainly but not no i i was around and
i remember it
and
i i don't believe that he should be
released i i don't believe hinckley
you know who's about to be
given the isn't he out uh
he's not in prison but he's unlimited
man i
so they're giving him 100
in january to go ahead and be free once
again not report they still put
restrictions on him he can't have a gun
you can't have this he can't have they
can't associate with this uh he's got to
stay away from jody foster
but i'm sitting there saying here's the
man that tried to kill the president of
the united states
wounded other people he's already been
busted you know he was after jody foster
the guy spent so much time
and does the good outweigh the bad the
the good is
somebody wants him free you know let him
get out let him lead a different
yeah but he may go back
but
the bad is
who are you gonna say i'm sorry to if he
does screw up
because there are no guarantees any to
this and if the crime isn't violent and
bad enough to keep him detained i don't
know what is uh look up francisco duran
and san francisco duran is still in
in prison because francisco duran
ran in a trench coat across the white
house he's the one that actually got the
white the street closed
and he shot at the white house
with a gun way back and if he's still in
prison
it says he was sentenced to 40 years in
the 90s so he should i haven't read the
whole article but he's probably still in
prison
i don't think david his name john david
hinckley hinckley
john hinckley john hinckley and now
who's john david hinckley i think he's a
cousin confusing like mark david chapman
soto or he's an american criminal cannon
oh that way
that was weird
uh so i googled i googled the david and
it gives me john warnock hinckley jr
so joan that's his full name
i think that's just a a level of a
federal crime that
that i think that
um if you're not mentally he wasn't
saying but mentally ill i don't think
that you get out right
i don't know
i mean i pulled up an article and i you
know i wasn't too familiar besides i
knew like the history bullet point of it
happening i didn't know that he was um
considered like criminally insane or
whatever the actual term is
um but apparently they've been you know
slow burn of like lifting restrictions
on him for since like 2003 yes they have
been yeah um
okay what would you say to your friends
uh parents or people out there that are
even young you know some people have
have bad genetics when they're young
about them being afraid to go to the
doctor man like like it's just to me
it's just a [ __ ] crazy thing because
if you only live once
and
i don't know where people live however
if it's a good if your people think it's
a good life or a bad life but you only
go around once and if you're sick it's
just you that you're hurting and your
families you're hurting too but if
if you have the ability to go someplace
and get better and you don't
well
is it genetic is it cultural is it
is fear cultural feel fear fear is
nothing more it's fear of the unknown
you have no idea when the guy comes when
the guy says to meet me in my office and
you go in there and he walks in there
now you're afraid and then you don't
even know what he said
yeah but it's real now but now it's real
yeah so you can't control
you can't i cannot control your fear
your fear is born within and when i say
born i mean it created inside abuse so
no matter what i say if you're fearful
you're really not going to pay attention
to me so i don't try and control
anybody's fear that's your fear
you've got it you've got to get rid of
it yourself i can't either that or seek
professional help maybe somebody
professional can help you but but i
can't because nobody's going to do that
yeah i don't want to create more damage
so you're on your own nobody's afraid
nobody that's afraid to go to the doctor
is going to go seek uh yeah exactly
you're afraid on the doctor you're not
going to see a brain death so
they're on their own i can't talk them
into it and i'm not going to waste a
bunch of time and effort trying to talk
but okay i'll say this
wasn't even that talked
okay so we're two for two on sponsors
too
let's say that let's say that
the all the guys that i grew up with
um
still do what they did even in the early
20s pretty much like they still work in
the same places and
they really kind of haven't you know
i said they haven't evolved but
they got married and they're still
friends with all the people that they
saw back when they were 20s
so if they have an issue
and also another thing is like you know
when one of the parents
is getting older and has dementia or
alzheimer's they have to come and live
with that per with that family and then
that puts a strain on that family oh it
does and i i can tell you and
it's not i mean i would have a hard time
man if if
if i'm married and we're whatever and
then her mom comes and lives with us
because she's
older like i don't know and [ __ ] it she
lives 15 [ __ ] years
pissing in the living room because the
hospital bed you can't get down the hall
it smell like you're trying to watch
wheel of fortune yeah
yeah go
and the producer quit on me
it sounds like a misty record piss in
the air then okay
just about about urinating in different
countries my my mother-in-law when she
was getting up in age she had to go to
uh one of these uh rehab rehab centers
because she had a little minor surge she
goes in there and i remember somebody
telling us you walk into these rehab
places and you're looking for one if
they smell like urine
they're dirty dog you know they don't
clean up enough and they're going to
when they smell clean can we go point
counterpoint yeah go ahead how many how
many how many people do you think are in
there
and
in whatever the hospital 25 people
that are like older
whatever where was she going she was
going to a rehab from the hospital okay
she had to go rehab because i don't know
she broke her arm broke her leg i don't
know what you broke
something broke she had to go in there
and i and i told him she finally crossed
the line and you snapped and i went in
there and i told i told my my wife
i said it's your mom you have two
brothers tell you right now my mom she
wouldn't be here
you know i'd get her out of this place i
wouldn't let her live here so now she
goes on she gets out
going in life
and
we discuss things when
talking about my wife i said okay you
got your mom and your dad
if your dad goes
first
i said i mean if your mom goes first i'm
not concerned about your dad your dad
will back up people with all his
relatives you know and they'll be happy
over there and he loves it
but if he goes first what about your mom
he said well we'll have to find a place
we're not going to find a place for your
mom to live
i know
she would have said that yeah i said
your two brothers wouldn't she wouldn't
be comfortable with you two brothers
she'll be comfortable here
come time she dies if necessary she'll
move in with us
so she did
she came in with us
and that's where she remained
i told her brothers
that i would say nothing until a point
in time that her
living with us impacted my family
wow and when it did
then i'm going to tell your brothers
okay now it's time you guys got to step
forward come up with some
money do something we got to find
another
uh place and she finally did get to that
point
where i said it's time you know i'm
set the brothers down i said okay it's
time you did you sat him down and you
said what did you say hey and it's it's
it's starting to impact my life you know
we cannot
now we've got to be here with her all
the time right we can't be doing this
can't be doing that she needs more care
and this isn't right and so they
understood
but fortunately for them or fortunately
for us
uh she went downhill real quick you know
so
we never did end up moving her into a
facility
she ended up getting bad enough there
you know paramedics came and i and i
told pearl i told my wife
okay now it's time now now it's time to
go look because this is no good
paramedics can be coming down here all
the time she's not getting any better
she's getting she needs medical
attention and so that's what we did and
but by that time
it was it was time we moved her into a
hospice
did uh either those brothers uh come
forward and say yeah
oh yes they they were in total agreement
and and both of them said hey you've
done everything you know whatever you
want to do you're the one that's been
taking care of her
wow they were pretty amazing i've never
seen that in uh it was it was well they
they both loved their mom it just i knew
without arguing without asking what the
easiest course would be
and i knew that i'd be the most
tolerable
so
it was it wasn't a big decision it was
easy and i knew that would make
my wife happier than anything else i
think a lot of people would not be
comfortable with that and still just
totally do it so i think that's also
what's cool about the stories um
you agree with that
yeah they would be some people would be
uncomfortable with it and not do it yeah
they'd still do it whether they're
comfortable or not i remember one time i
laughed with my son
because my mother-in-law had taken a
spill
and so needed to help her up get her and
get her up into the bedroom
and
i told my son i said imagine this i said
here i am picking your grandma up we're
taking her to the bed
i said she wouldn't even let me in her
house when i was dating your mom
and she hated me when we first got
married
so now
look how far we've come you know so yeah
it was all right but you know what you
were better to her than a lot of her
family was
i was uh can i say that i don't want to
cross the line no you you can say that
it was it was good her family was
supportive they just knew that
you know hey they're taking care of her
and they relied on her sister and her
sister which was my wife
relied on me it took the family so we
did it was he it was
it was the easiest way to go okay um
what what what happens in a situation
where
okay the husband and the wife are
married and then the mom gets sick and
the husband says i'd prefer that should
not be in the home
now now what happens i'm glad i'm not
i'm glad
but what do you think happens it becomes
an issue between the husbands
definitely sure and maybe and usually a
person at that uh i'll take another one
a person at that advanced age
doesn't have the money in the bank that
they would need or the insurance or
whatever to to uh
to give you experience
to go to a place where you know she's
not a burden on anybody yeah
and
uh
she wasn't
it was no
real burden on us she didn't
you know there it wasn't a burden on us
it was easy you know she was uh did you
sleep in a regular bed or did you have a
house no she she slept in a regular bed
matter of fact i have one of these beds
uh we have dual control so we can you
know
come up and back
and so all of a sudden she wanted one
she didn't want a regular she won one
then my wife told her mom those are
expensive i don't care that's what i
want so that's what she got did you like
it though did she pay for it yeah yeah
she did she wanted to she wanted that
special bed i'll buy
she won a special bed
she got what you know my my best friend
i grew up with his dad was in a hospital
bed
and uh he you know he'd be laying down
right there so when he'd come out of his
room he had to talk over the bed
and now i would say hey man you know
oscar de la hoya is fighting over the
staples center man and you know i want
to see if you want to go and i was like
yeah
and he would go and he would go i want
to go hey like hey puto you
no he forgot he hadn't been anywhere in
12 years but you know but with the willy
wonka but that but that's uh uh becomes
an issue you know my dad had it worse
than i i shouldn't say worse i didn't
have it bad
okay give my number again because let's
say i want to see this because you know
what
i think it's
it's a huge thing man
um
when the when like you you were cool
okay yeah number's up on the screen 813.
say what it is that that
that someone's mother's ill
and the the husband or the wife says
i have a problem with with her moving in
and us taking care of her
is that the right is that the right yeah
that's what you want to know and i just
think that's a selfish outlook on either
the one that doesn't want her in there
whether it be right or wrong i agree
that that's a selfish people are selfish
and then they have their place what they
like you know what then they maybe they
have a room where they go
watch sports and then that's not the
room anymore because somebody's staying
in there and and you know and all of a
sudden a place where you would go to
have peace and quiet and enjoy something
that that you could do in there and
everybody knew that when you were in
there that you were watching something
that you like now that's not your place
anymore i think marriage is a give and
take and you got to work together and so
therefore
to neglect the other side is a one-sided
opinion you know you're self-centered
you're thinking about your happiness and
your happiness alone without taking
under consideration
the spouse's feelings and you know what
it might cause you know and unless there
were underlying feelings you know unless
the mother-in-law tried to kill somebody
when when or in the family
i i think that's exaggerated i i think i
think it's more superficial than that oh
i i would think so yeah i think it's
just i think it's just that you're used
to being in a place and you're used to
to to doing whatever you're gonna you do
and then now if you call your your wife
and she's in there with their mom
and helping her do whatever and then now
i don't know man i mean that that's what
convalescent knows and hospital homes
and all the other places i remember my
my in-laws lived there in the end before
my father-in-law passed away they lived
no more than five minutes away from me
and when he started getting dementia and
he started having medical issues he
needed more help i was telling the wife
hey
go stay with them you know you're right
over the hill i can see all that anytime
stay with them give them all the help
they want because they're not going to
be around forever
and god knows if they die and you're
over here i don't want you to feel the
guilties i could have done more
i'm not going to you know okay i can
survive without you i understand that
let me leave a situation
call in put that number back up yeah i
didn't even finish
1843. there you go eight one eight five
three three one eight four three on your
radio dial call in we wanna hear about
this
you